I was reading a little bit about the
possible Blum House production that
might shoot on the universal lot soon
and you know I'm a great admirer of your
company in the way that your productions
work so the idea of you potentially
setting the blueprint for future
production shooting given the
circumstances right now is is very
encouraging to me so what is some tool
or some way of working that you think is
gonna change the game in that respect
that you're gonna put into practice on
that movie we're not gonna put into
practice anything different than what
the the governor is is suggesting and
that and I think the the thing that I'm
most focused on is making sure that that
obviously we're doing we're putting a
plan together with all the Guild's and I
want to make sure the guilds are
comfortable and feel good about the plan
as opposed to coming up with the plan
and just saying hey this is what we're
doing can we get your your rubber stamp
of approval because they obviously have
have they want to get their members back
to work but they obviously have a ton of
concerns and so I think I think what
we're doing most differently on this
movie is taking the guidelines from the
government and then concocting a plan
with our you know friends at all the
guilds so that we do something that that
not just we or Universal but that all of
you know all of the people that we work
with and their representatives feel feel
positive about that and get a consensus
and and it's been going well it's an
enormous of an enormous amount of work
but it's been moving slowly but surely
forward and knock on wood now not for
sure but uh but I think we'll be able to
shoot something in in about six weeks
I'm rooting for you guys I I know that
people sometimes roll their eyes of you
know people obsessing over movies and TV
right now but I know I for one need
content like that in order to be able to
process the real stuff that I'm living
through so thank you for being in
eliminating new films and new content
[Laughter]